hey guys this is Rob and in the
forthcoming video I made a couple errors
and some statements that I made the
first was that I stated that with the
example of carnage that the symbiotes
take on the attributes of the host that
they take over and that's actually
incorrect the symbionts are their own
organisms there they can think they can
feel they can make their own decisions
and they're actually considered to be a
mutant among their own their own species
so the symbiotes function best when they
have the same kind of attributes that is
to say the same feelings and emotions
and thoughts as the host they take over
that's why the Venom symbiote bonded so
well with Eddie Brock because they both
hated spider-man and as far as the the
statement that Galactus goes I had made
this day when they Galactus was a human
being I made that statement in error I
recognized a clock it's not a human
being
apparently just wasn't paying attention
at the time Galactus is more of a cosmic
entity but I go further into that in the
video so with that being said let me
know you guys think I'll get you guys
later peace
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I wanted to have a discussion
about good and evil the philosophy
behind good and evil and the Marvel
Comics because in the Marvel Universe
there are a litany of characters that we
could consider to be villains but they
may not be wholly evil
now I'm not denying that there are
inherently evil characters in the moral
universe
for example carnage is an inherently
evil character he is the symbiote the
same kind of symbiote that attached
itself to Eddie Brock and became venom
but the difference between carnage and
venom is that one the symbiote attaches
to the bloodstream of Cletus Kasady
and two when assembly it takes on a host
it takes on the traits of that host and
Cletus Kasady was a sadist murderer he
was absolutely insane and so carnage
began to conduct itself in the same
fashion but individuals who are
perceived as being evil but not
inherently evil are the most intriguing
most intriguing characters to me and for
this video I want to use two main
examples I want to use Galactus and I
want to use apocalypse and the reason
why is because their belief systems and
the way that they choose to conduct
themselves are motives that we would
consider to be evil but are not
inherently evil they're simply
perceptions of how we define good and
evil so in order to understand them as
characters we kind of need to understand
their backstory and I'm also assuming
that those of you who are watching this
video at least a good majority of you
are unaware of these characters Assad
for maybe Galactus being mentioned and
one of the Fantastic Four films in which
case Galactus wasn't very well defined
in that film so starting with Galactus
Galactus is optionally a being called
Galan and he was the sole survivor of
the previous universe the one thing to
bear in mind is that in the Marvel
comics of course they have beings like
The Living Tribunal which is directly
under the one above all who for all
intents and purposes is more or less
kind of God and the Marvel Comics but
there have there have been and will
continue to be multiple universes each
one coming after the other when the
previous universe pretty much kind of
collapses on itself and that's where
Galactus came from Galactus is the imbue
meant or the embodiment of all of the
sentience and the previous universe
combined into one and so his powers are
astronomical
and multiple entities in the cosmos
let's say eternity and death for example
argue that apocalypse is a necessary
part of the natural order of things if
he didn't exist there would be horrible
consequences and indeed there is
actually a point where he is effectively
kind of killed and the result is a
character named Abraxas that we won't go
into but he was a he was a pretty
horrible guy but nonetheless Galactus in
order for him to survive he has to
travel from one planet to another
consuming the life force of that planet
and then moving on to the next he
doesn't do it by virtue of the fact that
he enjoys inflicting pain on people he
simply does it because it's necessary
for him to exist with apocalypse it's a
little bit different apocalypse was for
all intents and purposes the first
mutant ever born and when he was born
into his tribe he was abandoned by it
because he he was born with grey skin
and with these blue lips and lines
running up running up along the side of
his face the the face whole facial
attributes that he has in this picture
that's the way that he looked when he
was born because he was abandoned he was
adopted by a group called the sandstorm
erse and their leader Baal ba al had
adopted him and raised him as his own
now this group had a very extremist
Darwin viewpoint that is to say only the
only the strongest deserve to survive
and this was a viewpoint that apocalypse
would hold now the reason why I say why
chose to use apocalypse even you know
despite having that viewpoint is because
he takes what most of us consider to be
an evolutionary standpoint he simply
argues that those who cannot survive
don't deserve to survive and Darwinism
takes the exact same approach evolution
isn't random chance evolution is not
things just kind of happen I mean
evolution doesn't take lives and throw
them into into a jar and shake it out
pour it out and just see what has you
know see what happens evolution is a
progress evolution will create an
organism if that organism is unable to
survive then it will die off and
evolution will try it again except it
will change something and if that
creature is able to survive in that
environment it'll
thrive and it'll grow and it'll evolve
into something else
apocalypse more or less kind of speeds
this process up he basically implements
a series of plan summit take place
thousands of years in the future and
work their way back whether because
someone like cable jumps back in time
someone like strife jumps back in time
or he actually implements them in the
past and watches them play out as time
progresses but the fact remains that he
more or less kind of speeds up this idea
of evolution apocalypse is really kind
of intriguing in this concept of the
idea of evolution because his inherent
mutant powers are not anything
spectacular what apocalypse was first
born he had superhuman strength
superhuman stamina and with those two
things combined superhuman speed he had
invulnerability some measure of animal
owner ability of the very least
immortality and the ability to take on
or give away mass in order to grow or to
to shrink in size respectively there
came a point in his history it was
somewhere around 1100 AD or something
like that where he came into contact
with celestial technology by a mishmash
of different circumstances where he
almost died and because he was able to
merge with celestial technology he was
given an offer by a being named exon who
was a celestial and he said either you
can take on this technology and move
forward and some you know at some point
in the distant future have to pay for
these gifts that we've given you or you
can go from here and forget everything
that you that you know so far and of
course he accepted and he was imbued
with a litany of new powers I mean he he
can he can control his entire molecular
structure and grant himself any
superhuman power that you could imagine
short of being able to alter reality and
time travel he is a genius you know just
having been around for thousands of
years and a lot of characters that exist
in the Marvel Comics exist because of
him but nonetheless we're kind of
digressing a little bit the very
argument of saying that apocalypse is an
inherently evil human being is
tantamount or it is synonymous with
saying that that evolution in and of
itself is inherently evil now we can
offer different justifications and say
the fact that apocalypse introduced the
legacy virus because he introduced the
techno-organic butter's and he killed
off people unnecessarily who could have
simply just sir
on their own isn't inherently evil act
but again and we could make the argument
we could say that human beings as they
stand now in the Marvel Universe are not
mutants and because they're not mutants
one of two things will happen because of
the rate in which mutants are being born
humanity will cease to exist or at
somewhere along the line existing humans
will develop mutant powers regardless of
the scenario non-powered mutants or an
unpowered human beings
non non mutants basically will
eventually die off simply by the aspect
of evolution so the question becomes is
there really a difference between what
apocalypse wants to do and what
evolution has been doing since the dawn
of life on the planet Earth down to the
first amoeba with Galactus Galactus is
not an inherently evil human being
because one he is an intricate part of
reality he simply has to exist for him
to exist is no different for a black
hole to exist that sucks in life and
destroys planets and solar systems he
simply does it in order to survive now
to say that what he does in order to
survive is wrong is to simply say that a
person that's attempting to survive to
preserve their own life is wrong for
doing so which goes against the basic
fundamental principles of what I
consider to be the definition of
humanity now when you get into the to
the nitty-gritty of defining right and
wrong this is when things get even a
little bit murkier the definition of
right and wrong and I'm actually kind of
scooting away from Marvel Comics and
just talking about you know more of a
philosophical stance here the definition
of right and wrong is relative to the
society in which we exist we create laws
that say don't kill people not because
we think killing is wrong but because we
don't want to have to worry about being
killed indiscriminately we make laws
that say don't steal from people not
because we believe stealing is
inherently wrong but because we don't
want to have to worry about consistently
coming home and finding our house having
been smashed into we make these laws in
order to keep ourselves safe to provide
some measure of protection and to
maintain order in society so the
question that I posed is do good and
evil truly even exist but going by the
standard that we've created here by
going by the standard of saying that
these constructs of good and evil are
not necessarily a reflection of what
good and
we'll truly are but are actually a
reflection of what we choose to use in
order to organize society we now live in
characters like apocalypse and Galactus
and ask the question are these
inherently evil beings do they define
what we consider to be good and evil or
what good and evil actually are or are
they simply just characters who exist
and are carrying out the natural order
of things or simply trying to maintain
their survival and to me this is why
it's so interesting this is why it's so
intriguing again I don't mean to say
that there are not evil characters in
the Marvel Comics for those of you guys
who are having a nerdgasm but I just a
little bit of nerd rage at this point
I'm sorry I had and those are total
opposites but for those of you guys who
were going into a little bit of nerd
rage at the moment I don't mean to say
there are not inherently evil
individuals but when it comes to a lot
of villains understood we kind of wanted
to raise the point and say that not
everyone is really an evil being
sometimes they just do things because
it's the natural order of things they
are imposing the natural order of things
by speeding it up a little bit or
they're simply just trying to live so
without being said I'm gonna go ahead
and wring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I'll catch you
guys later peace